Traduttore: Cecilia Bernabeni
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Buongiorno.
Credo che ci sia un aspetto
che forse condividerete con me,
e cioè la percezione di insicurezza
che ci pervade ormai da qualche anno.
La sicurezza è un'insicurezza economica,
un'insicurezza dovuta alla criminalità.
Però questo confligge poi con i dati
che in realtà riguardano la criminalità.
Perché se noi andiamo a vedere,
in questo spaccato abbastanza ampio,
dal 2004 fino al 2016,
ci renderemo conto
che gli omicidi e tentati omicidi
sono diminuiti terribilmente.
E se facciamo lo stesso confronto
con gli altri paesi d'Europa,
vedete l'Italia in quel rettangolino,
be', possiamo dire che l'Italia
è un'oasi felice.
Questo grazie soprattutto
all'autorità giudiziaria,
grazie alle forze di polizia
che, ogni giorno,
sacrificano anche la loro vita
per darci la sicurezza.
Però c'è qualche cosa
che nel frattempo è accaduto,
ed è accaduto a partire
dagli anni Ottanta.
Io è lì che inizio la mia attività
come biologo forense.
Qui vedete un caso
che ha segnato la storia criminale,
e anche la storia italiana,
e cioè il sequestro e l'omicidio
dell'onorevole Moro.
Ma quello sul quale
voglio attrarre la vostra attenzione
è, vedete, questa
frequentazione del luogo,
soprattutto la calca intorno alla Renault
in cui, ricorderete,
fu trovato morto l'onorevole Moro,
che in realtà per noi rappresentava,
allora come oggi, la scena del crimine.
Però nessuno era cosciente
che quella scena andava tutelata,
che andava protetta.
E allora proprio da quegli anni
si è sviluppata progressivamente
la prova scientifica.
Cioè, la prova scientifica
è entrata nell'attività investigativa,
e io ho avuto il privilegio
di vivere proprio questa progressione.
Ma se riavvolgiamo un po' il film,
dobbiamo anche ricordarci,
ce lo ricorda Svetonio
nelle "Vite di Cesare",
che la prima testimonianza
dell'uso della prova scientifica
è nella autopsia di Giulio Cesare.
E la fa Antistio.
Antistio è il medico curante
di Giulio Cesare,
ma si trova costretto a determinare
quali siano state le cause della morte.
Quale colpo d'arma da taglio
ha causato la sua morte.
Per arrivare poi al primo caso,
un caso di violenza sessuale,
seguito dall'omicidio,
di due giovani ragazze, in Inghilterra,
in cui per la prima volta,
siamo negli anni '84-'86,
viene utilizzata la prova del DNA.
Il DNA fa ingresso in questo panorama
e si presenta come una possibilità
che diventerà irrinunciabile
e straordinariamente forte
per assicurare alla
giustizia i delinquenti.
Ma tutto quello che noi facciamo
nei nostri laboratori,
così come nella scena del crimine,
lo dobbiamo a quest'uomo,
un antesignano da questo punto di vista,
Edmond Locard,
che nel 1910 coniò un principio,
il "Principio di interscambio di Locard",
che si condensa in una frase
piena di fascino e di attualità:
"Ogni contatto lascia una traccia".
Se ci pensate,
qualsiasi frequentazione noi facciamo,
personale o di ambienti,
in quelle frequentazioni
noi lasciamo delle tracce
e estraiamo altre tracce
che diventano i testimoni
dei nostri contatti, del nostro percorso.
Beh, questo ha fatto sì
che tutte quelle scienze
che, fino ad allora,
non avevano avuto uno sviluppo
accanto all'attività investigativa,
diventano le scienze forensi.
E cioè la biologia, la chimica,
la fisica, l'ingegneria,
concentrate proprio nella necessità
di poter dare delle risposte a che cosa?
A dei reperti, e a delle tracce
che sono sulla vittima,
che sono sulla scena del crimine.
Vedete, questo è un elenco
sicuramente parziale;
ma oggi, proprio in virtù
della grande potenza delle scienze,
noi possiamo dare
un senso e un significato
agli insetti, ai pollini,
alle vernici, alle fibre,
non vi cito naturalmente le tracce
più convenzionali, come quelle biologiche.
Tutto può essere importante,
per legarci a quell'evento
e indicarci le responsabilità.
Ma naturalmente,
non soltanto tracce fisiche.
Perché oggi a quelle
si sono sommate le tracce psicologiche,
quelle che vanno a studiare la vittima,
che ne traggono elementi per capire
quale può essere stato il movente
e ancora una volta comprendere
quale può essere quella rosa di sospettati
per quel determinato reato.
E poi, naturalmente,
le tracce informatiche
e tutto quello che noi lasciamo
attraverso i nostri dispositivi,
il telefono -
e lasciamo non solo
le tracce delle nostre comunicazioni,
ma anche della nostra posizione.
E devo dire che se il DNA, nel 1984,
ha rivoluzionato il modo
di fare le indagini,
l'informatica forense
ha sicuramente superato
queste possibilità che la genetica aveva.
Ma è tutto così semplice?
Eh no, sarebbe assolutamente noioso.
Non saremmo lì, costantemente
immersi nella ricerca.
Perché molte tracce sono invisibili.
E un modo per cercare
le tracce invisibili,
sia quelle biologiche
sia quelle non biologiche,
è l'uso, ad esempio, delle lampade forensi
che sfruttano lo spettro
completo della luce
che, sapete, è costituito
da frequenze d'onda
che vanno dall'ultravioletto
all'infrarosso,
e ci consentono, come in questo caso -
questa era una maglia
vestita da un omicida -
di far chiarezza su delle tracce -
che non vedete -
all'interno di questa maglia,
ma che, illuminata all'infrarosso,
ci dà la possibilità di individuare tracce
che hanno una genesi differente.
Ci sono tracce da contatto,
ci sono tracce da proiezione
che riscontrate poi con le dichiarazioni
di questo - indagato allora,
imputato e condannato dopo,
hanno fatto sì di poter capire
che tutto quello che raccontava
era assolutamente mendace.
E poi c'è la chimica.
La chimica, come il luminol,
molto famoso in fondo nelle indagini,
anche in quelle
che vengono proposte dai media.
Ma è una reazione che,
insieme e accanto
alla presenza di emoglobina,
anche in quantità estremamente ridotte,
permette di vedere effettivamente
se ci sono ancora delle tracce.
Quelle due fotografie
che vedete da basso sono vere,
e si riferiscono, forse lo ricorderete,
al duplice omicidio di Novi Ligure
in cui prima, a sinistra,
vedete una cucina
che è caratterizzata
soltanto da tanta sporcizia,
a parte quei segni fatti col gesso;
e a destra, invece, vedete
le orme di piedi insanguinati
che hanno scandito i movimenti
e quindi il comportamento di Omar Favaro,
che era uno dei due assassini
di quella famigliola.
Poi ci sono strumenti di misura,
come il laser 3D,
che ci permettono non solo di misurare,
ma di modellare e quindi di fare ipotesi
che riguardano, appunto,
quella che è stata la dinamica.
E poi, vedete, due mondi
completamente differenti.
Quello di Giulia, così creativo;
quello un po' cruento
che riguarda invece il mio lavoro.
Ma anche io mi occupo di macchie,
di macchie di sangue.
Perché noi andiamo ad osservare
la forma, le dimensioni e la distribuzione
delle macchie di sangue.
Perché una macchia,
quando si muove nell'atmosfera,
come vedete in questa veloce animazione,
è una palletta -
dicendolo in un termine
più tecnico, è uno sferoide,
che si accorcia e si allunga
soltanto perché risente
della forza di gravità.
Ma le macchie di sangue
non solo sono soggette
alla forza di gravità.
Perché?
Perché compiranno una traiettoria,
saranno proiettate da una forza.
E allora, da questo punto di vista,
vediamo un'altra animazione
e vedete come, con un solo evento,
noi otteniamo una popolazione
di tracce ematiche.
Naturalmente, quando poi
interveniamo su quella scena
è chiaro che la gamba non c'è,
il piede non c'è;
ma noi sappiamo ex-post ricostruire,
in funzione di quelle morfologie
e di quelle traiettorie,
qual è stata l'area di origine,
cioè da quale punto
quelle tracce si sono generate.
E questo, accanto
alla possibilità di capire:
sono tracce soggette
alla sola forza di gravità,
quindi gocciolamento o contatto?
O sono tracce da proiezione?
Ma pensate anche le aree
non caratterizzate dalle tracce,
cioè le aree di vuoto.
Ci danno delle informazioni su che cosa?
Su quella che è la posizione
reciproca aggressore-vittima,
che poi ricostruiamo
grazie alla disponibilità di software
che oggi hanno facilitato moltissimo
le nostre attività.
Io, quando ho iniziato,
negli Stati Uniti, a occuparmi di questo,
beh, non vi dico, era forse
ancora forse più affascinante di adesso;
ma misuravo macchia per macchia,
tiravo le stringhe,
cioè dei fili più o meno rigidi,
mi calcolavo le traiettorie
e con lo studio delle singole traiettorie
arrivavo a determinare
quello che voi vedete qui,
l'area d'origine,
senza strumenti informatici.
Meno male però che ci sono.
E allora vi voglio raccontare un caso:
è un caso vero, è un omicidio.
Che però parte come un suicidio.
Il "suicidio" di Valentina Salamone.
La vedete lì, è quella ragazza sospesa
da quella fune, nella foto a sinistra.
Tutti pensano che Valentina
si sia suicidata,
perché è in crisi col suo ragazzo,
è in crisi con la vita,
e con la sua famiglia.
E per molti giorni,
questo caso viene affrontato
come un suicidio.
Ma c'è un padre.
La mia storia professionale
mi fa incontrare molti padri
che vogliono giustizia.
Che si impone, che non ci crede,
che vuole veramente capire
che cosa è successo.
E allora riuscirà a far sì
che la procura generale avochi l'indagine,
e quindi abbandoni quello
che era stato fatto fino a quel momento,
per cercare di fare degli approfondimenti.
Questi approfondimenti
li vedete, sintetizzati,
in quel sandalo che indossava Valentina
quando è stata uccisa prima
e sospesa dopo;
e vedete sulla destra, cerchiato di rosso,
una macchia di sangue, un accumulo.
Beh, se notate, i piedi di Valentina
hanno il tallone più alto
rispetto alle dita.
Ma questa macchia, che voi vedete
a destra sul sandalo,
è nella posizione nettamente contraria.
Significa che Valentina
è stata ferita prima,
ed è stata mantenuta in una posizione
assolutamente diversa dalla sospensione
quando era già ferita.
Ed è stata poi sospesa "in limine vita",
cioè quando stava morendo.
Perché morirà per asfissia,
ma a seguito delle lesioni
che qualcuno le ha provocato.
E allora questo aspetto,
questo particolare così importante
farà sì che si possa
approfondire ancora di più,
fare una sperimentazione -
si chiama esperimento giudiziale,
cioè quello di utilizzare una persona
della stessa corporatura di Valentina
per dimostrare che non poteva
far tutto da sola,
che non sarebbe riuscita
né a passare la corda su quella trave,
né tantomeno a formare quel nodo.
E allora, poi, tutto questo
avrà un ulteriore approfondimento,
perché quei sandali ci diranno poi
chi, in ipotesi, è stato.
Dico così perché siamo ancora
nella fase del processo di primo grado
e quindi è giusto presumere l'innocenza
fino a quando non si celebri
il terzo grado di giudizio.
Ma il "chi" era il suo ragazzo,
che lascerà delle tracce
all'interno di questo sandalo,
miscelate naturalmente
con il sangue di Valentina.
Un caso che sarebbe finito
come un suicidio,
ma che appunto celava un omicidio.
Grazie proprio a questo studio -
vedete la sintesi, il binomio DNA
e BPA, lo studio delle tracce di sangue.
Beh, devo dire che da biologo
non avrei mai pensato
a questa evoluzione del DNA.
Ormai sono 30 anni che lo utilizziamo,
e io ho avuto il privilegio,
se di privilegio posso parlare,
accanto alla tristezza,
di occuparmi di un caso
altrettanto tragico,
e cioè la strage di Capaci.
Qualche giorno fa, appunto,
abbiamo ricordato quell'evento.
E mi occupai insieme al dottor Spinella
dell'analisi di quelle cicche di sigaretta
che poi ci consentirono
di risalire al comando,
insieme naturalmente
alle indagini tradizionali.
E poi avete visto quanto il DNA,
e grazie soltanto, forse, al DNA,
siamo arrivati a capire
chi fosse l'omicida di Yara Gambirasio.
Con uno screening genetico
per la prima volta così ampio,
cioè l'analisi di più di 20.000 DNA,
per arrivare a capire
quale fosse la paternità,
di chi fosse la paternità
di quella traccia di sangue.
Ma il DNA non è
soltanto questo: è banca dati,
e per fortuna anche noi
abbiamo una banca dati ormai.
Ma è DNA non soltanto umano,
perché è DNA vegetale, DNA animale.
C'è un caso per il quale
già i media hanno parlato
e per il quale, sicuramente,
conoscerete presto dei particolari,
che è quello di un altro "cold case",
cioè l'omicidio di Serena Mollicone,
che è stato risolto,
o comunque ha dato elementi importanti,
grazie al DNA
che lo legava a dei frammenti
vegetali di una porta.
Quindi pensate alla potenza,
effettivamente, di questo DNA,
che naturalmente oggi
ci dà la consapevolezza
di poter risolvere
tantissimi casi non risolti allora,
quelli che si chiamano cold case
o casi a pista fredda,
come l'omicidio dell'Olgiata
che è stato risolto 17 anni dopo
che era stato commesso,
anche qui con degli errori
investigativi incredibili.
Ma non solo questo, perché il DNA
è affascinante quanto potente.
E non ha limiti, perché
le nuove possibilità che ci offre
è quello di individuare
il colore degli occhi,
il colore dei capelli,
il peso, la forma del volto,
cioè elementi investigativi
che sono preziosi,
soprattutto nella fase
iniziale delle indagini.
E non [c'è] solo il DNA.
Per questo la ricerca
è estremamente affascinante.
Pensate alla popolazione di microrganismi
che ognuno di noi si porta addosso
e che è diventato un altro strumento
di identificazione, o di individuazione,
dell'intervallo di morte.
E che dire degli odori,
cioè di tutte quelle sostanze,
anche quelle variabili in ognuno di noi
per le nostre abitudini
e per la nostra professione,
per il nostro modo di vivere,
che stanno diventando un altro presidio
per l'identificazione.
Tutto questo, però,
ha sempre poi una finalizzazione.
E non posso, in conclusione, non citare
questa iniziativa statunitense
che si chiama The Innocence Project,
che anche in Italia
ha avuto i natali qualche tempo fa,
un'iniziativa che è partita
proprio dalla consapevolezza
che il DNA poteva risolvere
tanti casi irrisolti.
E guardate:
dal 1989, 365 persone
riconosciute innocenti.
Ma la cosa strabiliante
è che 20 di queste
erano state condannate a morte.
Ed erano degli innocenti.
E sono stati salvati
dal DNA, dalla scienza.
E in più del 50% [dei casi]
questi soggetti hanno consentito poi-
il loro esonero ha consentito,
attraverso una nuova analisi del DNA,
di individuare i veri autori.
Allora, quali risvegli?
Beh, io direi: il risveglio
dell'impegno sociale;
il risveglio del senso di responsabilità,
della passione, della ricerca costante,
della dedizione verso i nostri cittadini.
Perché come ci ha detto [Hemingway]:
"Il mondo è un bel posto,
e per esso vale la pena di lottare".
Grazie.
(Applausi)